julia in salt lake city julia
what's up i feel singing this morning
man what is up julia
hi dr d um so i have a question
in regards to my marriage and my
husband's video game playing
um he plays hold on hold on did you just
say my husband's video game play
yes oh my gosh james and kelly
so far today we have had the downloading
operating system into kids
we've had parents who don't take their
kids to funerals
and the trifecta you tell me you got a
husband who plays video games i got to
hear more about this go for it
yeah so um it gets excessive i mean it's
always excessive
but i there are like two versions of him
there's a version that can like
balance that with normal life and then
there's a version of him
that ignores everything else and can't
deal with real life
can't hold a conversation doesn't want
to go to family events doesn't want to
talk to his mom
doesn't want to play with our daughter
like it's so
bad and he's had this problem since
early childhood i didn't know how bad it
was until after we were married
um so this has been going for like 25
years
at this point um because his mom just
couldn't ever like pull the plug on it
when he was a kid
what a failure why did she not do that
she
she tried single mom tried to do
her best she thought just changing the
password on the computer was enough but
he
got his own computers and he'd play all
day and through the night and
okay can i stop you right there because
i want to i want to say this publicly
this is not to you this is to everybody
out listening a parent who comes to me
and says hey my
nine-year-old is addicted to their ipad
i'll always stop them and say that's
bull crap
nine-year-olds only get ipads through
their parents
period end of story in the discussion
my kid won't stop playing video games
then you take the controllers and you
smash them into a million pieces kids
only have
access to this nonsense when their
parents are either too insecure or i'll
give it to you they're exhausted
i understand that and a single mom
trying to navigate
their day and two jobs in school i
understand handing a kid a controller
because it just keeps everybody happy i
get that i get it i get it
but i this i just couldn't pull the plug
that's
that's it's parents not owning up to
their responsibilities and stepping in
that gap
and getting rid of the freaking
controllers all right that's
that's my aside go go back julia
yes you're good um so when i met him
while we were dating he was hardly
playing at all
as far as i could tell um he was really
involved in church he was really
thoughtful about dating
uh we had like a really good social
circle and
we were just like always out and about
doing stuff he took good care of himself
and then after being married for a
little bit we've been married for four
years now
um like every six months or so i just
have to have like a complete breakdown
to snap him out of it because he's just
lost in his video game world and what
does lost mean
like how many hours a day like
at an absolute minimum three to four
hours typically after a work day
seven to eight hours and then on
weekends probably like double that
at least wow so this is a full-blown
lifelong addiction yeah like he gets
home from work and i'm like hey i need
you to take care of the baby and he's
like okay give me a minute and he goes
and logs in on
his computer and i'm like wow so are
these the the multi
uh a multi-online player games does he
have a whole community that he's going
to
like trolls and frogs and navy snipers
that he's running around with
yeah it's it's so it's really strange
sometimes he's like oh yeah
it's all about the community it's
because you know like i need like my
boys he doesn't know any of these people
in person and he never will
right because they're not real and other
times yeah or they're
yeah other times though he's just
mindlessly clicking and it's the same
game he's played since he was a kid
and i i actually like banned it for a
while i was like i'm done
i like this has to go away and he
humored me for like three or four months
and then
one day he was like yeah so i downloaded
on my phone
and i've been playing during my lunch
breaks and so i don't think it's that
much of a problem and he put it back on
his computer again and
what is your sex life like what is your
intimate life like
it's it's kind of gone away some of that
has to do with our baby being born this
year
and just sleep deprivation and c-section
recovery and ptsd
and a number of things um so back me up
right before the baby was born still
four to six hours i mean i'm just
looking at the math on the hours here
right i mean there's not a lot of time
to squeeze in
connection time no no there's not and i
told him that too
he's like like every once in a while
he'll say oh like you know like
our intimate life has disappeared i'm
like yeah because like i'm not a
microwave you can't just push a button
and i'm ready to go like you have to
actually pay attention to me
we have to do date night we have to
cuddle sometimes without the expectation
that that's going to happen
it takes effort on your part and so
sometimes he puts in that effort and
other times he's like i
like it's too much i'm just going to
play my games because that's easy
wow so we'll talk about the video game
thing here in a minute
i don't want you to blow by the sense of
rejection
in the sense of um i wish i had a better
word for it i'm kind of at a loss right
now the infidelity that he's choosing
video games he's choosing
yeah rolling around with middle school
kids um
with his controllers as opposed to
being with his wife and i don't want you
to miss that
and i know that's easy to focus on the
video game part but that's gotta suck
right that hurts yeah that hurts
definitely
um so i don't want to to minimize this
there are guys who come home and numb
out
who don't either don't have the tools
and and women do it too right there's
men and women who don't have the tools
to be in relationships they don't have
the tools you said you got a young kid
right they don't have the tools
for dealing with the stress and the
overwhelming feelings of
shame and what do i do when a newborn
comes home they don't know how to deal
with rejection at work
that happens right and there's folks who
spend one or two or three hours a night
four to six hours a night eight to nine
hours a night
has so many derivative bad effects
from lack of sleep to lack of human
contact
to literally living in a fantasy
that's his every bit as far as i'm
concerned as dangerous
as an alcoholic addict as someone who's
cheating on their wife
because they are choosing other
behaviors or choosing
other fake relationships to numb out and
not have to deal with the person in
front of them
and so now that you've got a daughter
here
i want you to be very serious about
thinking through protecting your
daughter
and his daughter from this level of
disconnection because
she will quickly understand that she is
in second place to a computer
that she is in second place to a distant
father
more insidiously it'll be a distant
person who's in the same house
right and a kid can not not regulate
well but they understand the physical
presence dad isn't here
right dad left us dad moved out mom
moved away she's got a new husband
but when they're in the same room and
they're distant from you
kids will backfill that with this is my
fault this gap is my fault and they will
try
all sorts of connecting numbing
behaviors to try to bridge that gap
and this is a serious thing i
again just in my own house just for what
it's worth
there are no video game consoles my kid
wouldn't know how to turn a video game
on
now i'm i'm crazy about it right so i
know there's going to be a million
people
you think the crossfit community came
after me man the the video game folks
i get it right um but i want my kid to
experience
outside i want my kid to experience
playing baseball with dad just throwing
it back and forth i had to learn i'm
still having to learn
how to play dolls with my daughter how
to just be bored
and be connected with my kids and what
they think is interesting we're going to
think is interesting or
if i'm out doing yard work my kids are
coming with me if i'm going hunting or
fishing my kids are going with me
and that's part of the responsibility of
having kids
now i don't want to say all video games
are evil or whatever that's just the
stance i've taken
mainly because i can't control myself um
i i don't mind saying this again on this
podcast a few years ago
before i knew they were a bunch of
cheaters i was a a near religious astros
fan
and one of the things i gave myself for
a gift
was the mlb ticket and so i ordered i
got all the astros games just piped into
my house
and i found myself cutting home from
work and i would just go lay on the
couch i was exhausted i was on call 24 7
365 i was just working working working
and i just go lay down
and my son came in one day and he asked
me a question that was a dagger to my
soul
and i really haven't picked up
professional sports or college sports
since
because i'd get home and i'd say hey son
why don't you come lay down and watch
the game with me we love the astros
together
and he'd say well let's just go play
catch and i'd be like let's watch these
guys they're professionals
and that was my way of numbing out i was
exhausted i didn't want to go chase a
ball he was like six or seven he threw
the ball all crazy all over the place
and then one day he came in and asked me
this question hey daddy
and it wasn't a drama question it wasn't
a
um a guilt question he was just like a
seven-year-old or eight-year-old
asking for facts asking for data hey dad
do you love me as much as the astros i
was like
say what do you love me as much as the
astros
because i was laying on the couch
watching them and he was just standing
there
and i looked at him and said son i love
you more than i will ever ever love the
astros and i got up and turned off the
game
and i really haven't gone back i really
haven't gone back
because my son is more important my wife
is more important my daughter's more
important my community is more important
than living in a fantasy world then
living in
a fake world of elves and trolls and
shooter games and all the things while
the world is spinning and passing us by
so for you julia i you've got to
intervene you've got to intervene in a
significant way
and so i'm going to recommend you go
meet with a professional counselor
to get some tools on how to identify
your personal values the values you're
going to have in your home for raising
your daughter
and of course you're doing this with
them and i
you're gonna have to come up with some
or what behaviors
some or what ideas because at this point
this is a lifelong thing he is connected
to this box your husband is
he's connected to this game this this
pseudo-fantasy community
and he's not going to be able to turn it
off on his own and
you're not going to be able to have blow
ups you're not going to be able to
punish him
into recovery he's going to have to
decide i want human interaction
i want to learn how to be uncomfortable
with other people
i'm going to have to learn how to be
disappointed and feel ashamed
and feel nervous and feel
sexy and feel loved he's going to have
to learn how to do all those feelings
because
his mom didn't teach him his mom didn't
teach him
and it is what it is that's the husband
you've got right now
i hope beyond hope beyond hope he will
lean in
and say you are right my wife my
daughter my family my future is more
important
than an imaginary game i hope you will i
hope you will i hope you will
the tools are out there and the
resources are out there but at this
point julia all you can do is you can
take care of you
your thoughts and your actions and
you've got to protect that daughter of
hers
and so go see somebody asap start
working through this process
and then be ready to have a good deep
clarifying boundary filled conversation
with your husband
and one last piece of advice don't have
that conversation
one night at midnight when you're just
frustrated and you're angry set it up
put it on the calendar
make it a destination y'all go to
breakfast have somebody come
take your daughter for vacation and
y'all go have this conversation in a
controlled quiet setting and just say
enough
is enough i'm not going to share my life
and my daughter with a video game
period i hope i hope he turns around and
i hope he
realizes how important you and your
daughter are call me back in a few weeks
after you had this conversation after
you've had time to meet with a
professional i want to hear how this is
going
and if he wants to call me i'd love to
talk to him too have him give me a call
or shoot me an email at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com that'd be fantastic